this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money george campbell ramsey personality
host of the fine print on ramsey
networks is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your
relationships your money
your mental health issues your family oh
yes
yeah that's a subject and of course your
money is always so career we'll dip it
we'll dip into all of it here it's what
we do again triple eight eight two five
five two two five adam's in philadelphia
hi adam welcome to the ramsay show
how's it going great man what's up
um nothing much i i guess i just have a
question for you okay um
so the question is about downsizing um
it appears that my wife and i bought a
little bit too much house
and we've been here for two years and
we're sort of looking at the future and
thinking is it good to downsize to
accomplish our financial goals
okay
based on the fact that your house
payment is killing you or what
so
right now our house is about 30
of our um
take home in a month on a 30-year
mortgage
and that's just both of our income
and my wife we have two children and
we're expecting more on the way so
she's thinking about transitioning
to the home and um it just appears that
obviously i'm not gonna be able to cover
this on my own
so
i don't know if this is something crazy
to think about or we should really be
considering this downside
yeah well i think you've already
answered the question haven't you
if she's going to stay home if she's
going to stay home you can't pay the
payment didn't you just tell me that
well
yeah i mean it's not that
it's not that she needs to stay home but
it's obviously something that she would
like to do and
i don't know i i guess i just want to
know is it insane to think like
in our journey to get out of debt
is it
but also be able to enjoy our life and
enjoy our children and things like that
that we give up a home
a lot of our friends and family are
thinking we're crazy to do that to
downsize when we move into uh unless
they're gonna pay the payment they don't
get a vote
i guess that's true they're not
experiencing the stress that you guys
will experience so what would the the
percentage of your take-home pay be if
she stays home what do you make
so i make about 60 000 and she makes
about 65 000. okay a year so it's good
your household is going to be 60 of your
take-home pay you're going to go
bankrupt
and that's my concern yeah
you have to decide is she going to stay
at the job to keep this house or is she
going to stay home and you move
there's really no other option
yeah you're right you're right do you
guys have any other type of debt
no so we are out of debt um and we've
been really like chugging away um
tucking money away to try to pay off
this house and at least start putting
money for paying the south early but
we're also feeling the pressure from it
she went on maternity leave and uh that
was three some odd months where we were
dipping into our emergency savings
and not putting money towards you know
investments and towards the house
and that's when i really got thinking
about you're gonna burn yeah you're
gonna burn through that and then then
you're gonna get foreclosed on if you
just ignore this
okay right yeah i think you got it you
gotta
i personally think it's just a personal
opinion but everybody gets to have one
uh it sounds like her desire what you
what you stated was her desire is to be
at home with the kids right
yeah and if that's what she wants to do
and you all that's your value system
i think you'll come out fine by moving
down in house and what you're doing is
you're trading us a smaller house for
the opportunity to stay home with your
kids when they're small and i think
that's a great trade on as a value
system
we're putting kids ahead of houses i
like that trade
yeah yeah i think i do so yeah i think i
just needed but yeah but you can't do
both
yeah
it's not an option you don't have the
math to do both
and so don't sit there in denial and
then just let this sneak up on you and
go oh well look what happened you know
don't don't be caught off guard this is
a you you need to make a definite
decision that says the price of her
being at home is a smaller home that we
can afford regardless of what our
friends and family think we're not
asking their opinion she wants to be
home with the kids i want to be home
with the kids the kids want to be home
with the kids it's a good thing for mom
to be home with the kids we like this
this is a good value it lines up with
who we are as people this is you saying
all of these things then you trade a
smaller house from that and i've had
lots of friends that have done that over
the years and and then maybe when the
kids take off to elementary school maybe
she kicks back into her professional
career and you change you can change
gears again six years from now years
from now whatever this reminds me why we
teach what we teach around the
parameters of getting a house 15-year
fixed rate no more than 25 of your
take-home pay put 10 to 20 down because
it gives you those options because at
that point you've got a lot of margin to
do the baby steps and if someone wants
to stay home it's not going to destroy
your financial world so what i hate to
see is couples like this who they want
to have one stay home but it's eating up
so much of their take-home pay that
would crush them if they make a move
like this with the number of times in 30
years of sitting here in this chair that
i've taken
uh
a call that sounds like
oh i got this van payment and so i can't
afford to
to quit and be home with the kids and
the ladies like crying
and i want to be home with my kids and
i'm like well don't trade your van for a
kid
it's a trade sell the van
that's easy well it can't be without the
van well you can't do both i mean this
is you're not you're not congress you
want to have to make a choice and eat it
too yeah you have to make a choice you
have to make some math here and just go
but you know sometimes people don't even
think they go gosh if i got rid of the
van i could do this
oh ding it's like set free like him he's
like because you know what they're gonna
do you could hear it
what's he gonna do he's gonna sell that
house and downsize he is because she
wants to be home and he likes the idea
and they're in agreement and
everybody else's opinions well whatever
he's willing to do what it takes to get
what they really want yeah it is pretty
amazing the number of people that give
you opinions about your money that don't
have any money
and that aren't gonna and that aren't
gonna help you pay payments so yeah yeah
i mean what are you crazy selling my
truck have you lost your mind
um
didn't actually wasn't taking a poll
here you know it's just like but
a lot of broke people have an opinion
about money
maybe it's time for everyone to stop
taking a poll and do what's right for
themselves and their family george that
was like sorry philosophy stuff i'm
starting to hurt feelings like you i was
like it's rubbing off on me george that
was said way too nice to hurt anybody's
feelings
because it was posed as a passive
aggressive question so it wasn't even
feeling that's the millennial way maybe
it's time no maybe it's not time maybe
it's past time
yeah quit taking a poll on your life
yeah that's good i like that yeah don't
worry about the way it looks on facebook
worry about the way it looks in real
life oh
dang yeah
that hurt dave the seven people left on
facebook favorite one of all times is
rachel's whole thing on like no one gets
a 1994 used honda accord
and posts it on facebook and goes hey
hashtag blessed you know
that felt like a person
that's perfect you know me and my honda
civic my 09 civic with body damage that
you love so much george i'm going to
post a picture today on instagram
i'm going to be i'm going to be just
what we were talking about i'm going to
be the guy giving you pressure to get a
better car i'm not taking a pole dave
the difference is that you you actually
have the money you cheapskate you just
told me that we're not taking a poll so
i'm not doing it i'm keeping my car that
doesn't mean i i'll be just like those
other people i'm gonna talk as if you're
listening unless you're buying me a new
car dave then we'll talk well indirectly
is true the man has a point
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 dollars a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
four
three
[Music]
so a couple days ago george and i took a
call from an over-the-road truck driver
who's uh he had been talking with his
wife about trading cars
and uh without talking to him she went
and traded cars and went further into
debt he was pretty irate about that
um because they didn't we're not in
agreement about that and she just went
and did whatever she wanted to do and uh
we talked to him for a few minutes the
more we talked to him the more if you go
back and listen to the call
uh the more we were questioning what's
really going on because he's like he set
her up threw under the bus pretty much
and then we're like yeah i think you
probably you're over the road she's
pregnant she's got a baby doing nine
days
and
you probably there's something else
going on here you read between the lines
i actually said you may need to come off
the road and take care of your family
and you guys need to get in marriage
counseling so um she apparently was
listening
or went back and listened to the call
and disagreed with a whole bunch of her
uh the things her husband said about her
uh and the conclusions we came to about
her as a result uh and so forth so send
us a long email
and and so we thought it'd be fun to
kind of go back through that because
it's really interesting so here's the
deal um well let's just say okay i
listened yesterday got to hear the call
you took from my husband regarding the
purchase of a van resulted in financing
10k
i know responding probably won't get air
time to resolve the plethora of issues
you two seem to pick up on but i felt at
least i could provide some context for
my actions that would hopefully lead to
a rebranding of my sanity because i said
she may have lost her dadgum mine
and accountability for the situation the
truth is partially as you put it i was
backed into a corner and i bit back
so it sounded like they couldn't come
into agreement and he's on the road left
her you know stranded with a bunch of
kids and she just did whatever she
wanted to do kind of thing that's what's
my point and so
um then she goes on for about
a page and a half explaining why it's
okay to borrow money to buy a van and
all this stuff which of course is not
true
uh my husband didn't mention that he's
packed all of his things and moved out
that's true he did not mention that and
has taken half of our emergency fund
with him
about nine days before i deliver our
second child oh really that's just nice
no he didn't mention that because i
probably would have ripped him a new one
for doing that it's like if you're gonna
leave you don't leave nine days before
baby comes dube
uh you know this didn't just suddenly
happen so yeah we would have um george
and i would have teed off on him on that
me more than george but because george
is generally nice
uh she closes with i'm not stupid i've
not lost my mind but backed into a
corner with no other resources or
choices i think i can own this one and
that's after rationalizing again for
five paragraphs that buying the van was
a good idea so let's go back and recoup
regroup on this whole thing for a little
bit um number one
i don't like it
when any of you
none of us at ramsay like it when you
take our good common sense advice that
is meant for you to prosper in your
family and you weaponize it to use it on
your family
or weaponize it to use it on your spouse
there's a thing in here where he says
she says
he he refused any car i looked at
because he and he said dave always says
if the answer is no we don't do anything
if the answer if we can't come into
agreement the answer is no well that's a
general principle yes but what's going
on here is
you two are a hot mess
that's what's really going on here
both of you jessica you with your
rationalization
and which i completely understand how
you get there in the middle of him being
a control freak and you getting ready to
have a baby and i get all of that but
you rationalized your butt off girl i
mean it's ridiculous and and him with
his lying to us and weaponizing
advice that we give here and using it to
verbally thrash his wife with
um you you guys desperately needed
marriage counseling a long time ago
long time ago
uh long before he calls on this radio
show
and uh we certainly did not tell him to
pack up his stuff and move on and it
sounds like he did that you go back and
listen to the call nowhere did we even
intimate that he should do that we did
tell him you guys need marriage
counseling and baby doll you did need
marriage counsel you do need marriage
counseling it's
you guys are a hot mess you you you bow
up and just go do whatever the crap you
want to do and go deeply in debt and buy
a van that you shouldn't have
against his wishes which indicates that
you guys are not on the same page and
have serious marriage problems and he's
being a twerp and a control freak and
not coming up with some way to take care
of his pregnant wife and kids and get
her into a car that works well to that
end everybody wants what they want
instead of being instead of serving each
other in this marriage she says to quote
him i don't care if it has a welded
five-gallon bucket for the front seat
you'll drive what i pick or i won't
agree to it because dave says if you
can't agree you go with who says no that
is not that has never come out of here i
mean we don't that's just that's just
completely weaponizing
the advice here
so yeah jessica you have a mess your
husband is a mess you're in a mess
and you did a stupid thing in the middle
of all that and it hurt to have her
laundry aired out you know on national
radio well i don't blame her for that
too and i'll pick on ladies getting
ready to have a baby in nine days oh my
gosh
so uh but the point is
guys this is if you can't get together
on what to do with money it's not a
money problem if you can't get together
on what to do with your car it's not a
car problem
that's a marriage problem and it's
usually a selfishness problem
i mean she was selfish because she just
went and did whatever she wanted to do
he was selfish because he's like i'm not
going to agree to anything because i
don't like it and i'm on the road and
i'm going to hold all the power like he
has any power which apparently he didn't
so
uh you know it was just out of control
so the the inverse of this is
hey i love my wife and i understand
she's freaking out i gotta figure out
some way to get her in a different car
that is good for our future and going
further in debt is not good for our
future
instead of
i'm going to tell you what to do and
dave ramsey oh my god you twerp and they
they mentioned we didn't ask their
income they make 137 thousand dollars
yeah and it paid off a bunch of debt
right yeah how much was it it was a lot
uh thousand dollars in fifteen months
they paid off she says
so um
uh what you but you didn't ask what we
made she said well i didn't ask what you
made because that wasn't the question
the question wasn't it's not an income
it wasn't a math problem it was my wife
bought a car that we didn't agree to
problem
that was the call it wasn't like how
much money you make how much money you
make doesn't solve you know youtube not
getting along
so you can make 237 000 and still not
you still shouldn't go do that and he
still shouldn't put you in a position
that you felt like that was the only
thing you could do
so you two are being s you're hot mess
you're a hot mess and you need to be in
marriage counseling both of you
bad
and so because here's the thing
sharon ramsey goes and does that i'm
gonna have a problem but i'm also not
gonna put her in a position
that she feels like that's her only way
and if she feels like that's her only
way then she's got a serious cinderella
syndrome
like she deserves entitled and i'm
arrogant and whatever then we got
another issue going on and we're going
to be sitting down with with a
professional and helping us guide
through our relationship because
apparently we can't guide through it
ourselves and we've done that ten years
you know after we were married about ten
years we about killed each other that
year
and so we you know marriage counselor
saved our lives and our marriage
saved my life because she probably would
have killed me i'm asleep but um
but the uh uh but i mean you know and so
i can i distinctly remember driving the
crappy
you remember this is how bad it was you
probably seen these on the road they're
still out there the two-tone blue astro
vans oh yeah you remember those yeah
those are real ugly this is like the
minivan of minivans
and it had like a bazillion miles on it
and i fried the transmission out of it
pulling the boat because it wasn't
designed to pull a boat it was a
lightweight little thing
and i put a new transmission in it and
this thing i mean it stunk it had
cheerios like neck deep in it although
it was we raised little babies in it and
dogs and it was a mess
and she was over this fan
and
rightly so it was a piece of crap
and we were starting to make a little
money we finally got a little bit of
money and she's like i want to get a
suburban i want to get an suv i'm like
that's twenty thousand dollars might as
well be that gum two hundred thousand
dollars what do you mean well you got
twenty thousand dollars coming in down
there at your company our company you
keep telling me it's mine i want some of
the money out there by suv i'm like yeah
but that twenty thousand dollars we can
use to invest in this thing we're
working on and it's gonna make us a
hundred thousand if we buy this car for
twenty thousand and we went back and
forth and went
and we just we kept arguing about
finally i had this moment where i went
you know what it's not an either or it's
a win
and i said so okay we're gonna we need
to do the investment at the company and
we need to buy the car
and which one which one we do first
which one we do first is the only thing
that mattered and so we just put her
first she won there we go and you know
what when she won i won boom isn't that
interesting
here's the takeaway from this story dave
they've got a child on the way and right
now they're both being children we need
less children in this family
how's that
now you'll get another email george uh
oh yeah
we changed our brand
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost-sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
four
three
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it is tax season i don't know anyone who
loves that
unless you're an accountant even the irs
doesn't love it the truth is most of us
dread filing taxes it's a pain it's
confusing and if it wasn't bad enough
the tax software most of you use hits
you with extra hidden fees and they try
to sell you a bunch of debt while you're
signing up just kind to get your taxes
done
filing your taxes does not have to be
horrible
it does not we created ramsey smart tax
to give you software that you can
actually trust
smart tax has steps that are simple and
clear so you know you've done your taxes
right
no more headaches no second guessing
yourself
we'll never tack on surprises and we
won't sell your info to scummy companies
and we won't try to sell you a bunch of
debt while you're doing your taxes
and when you sign up for ramsey plus
it's even easier you can actually file
your federal taxes for free if you're a
ramsay plus member so
don't get taken advantage of by your old
tax software ever again time to make the
change
start your free trial of ramsey plus and
you can file your taxes free
at ramsey solutions dot com slash ramsay
plus ramsey plus is where you get
financial peace university and every
dollar and all that and now if you're a
member of that you also get
ramsey smart tax free
so go do your free trial get it all done
this is all free free free free free
free free it's crazy
ramseysolutions.com ramsay
plus
kathy's in buffalo new york hi kathy
welcome to the ramsey show what's up
hi um i'm a senior in college and
unfortunately i mean i work pretty hard
throughout college to like save up money
for a car and just like an apartment
after graduation and just for food and
living expenses
um and they had around like 25
000 saved up for my car and just like
after graduation but unfortunately kovid
kind of hit my family hard and my uncle
had to borrow money to pay for my
grandpa's hospital though i'm like my
grandpa my dad
um and now like they're not really
giving my money back if that makes sense
and i don't really know what to do about
it
how old are you
um 21
[Music]
how old's your uncle
oh
i mean i i don't know but probably 40
45. so this 45 year old comes to the 21
year old college kid and says i can't
pay my dad's hospital bill you need to
help
and you gave him your butt
[Music]
yeah yeah your family's a bunch of
irresponsible people aren't they
um yeah they're broke and they can't
take care of their grandpa and they come
to a kid to take care of them that's the
definition of irresponsible i'll help
you with that i shouldn't have been a
question should have been a statement
okay
how much money did you give them
um i mean because like you know hospital
bills are like extraordinarily expensive
like fifteen thousand good lord
so you give him fifteen thousand dollars
and what was the terms what was the plan
for him to repay you
um
like i said within like the next year
yeah and he said okay
yeah where was he gonna get the money
um the thing was like my aunt was out of
work um just because like she lost her
job and then she was going to pay me
back like once she got a job where's
your parents
um
my parents like my parents like my dad's
kind of arguing with my brother i mean
with his brother but like they kind of
the two of them are like having their
own fight about many issues
that's shocking
oh kiddo i'm so sorry you are in a mess
i just want to box your uncle's ears
and i wish you had i wish you had stood
up and just said no don't you
yeah i just didn't want like you know my
grandpa they're not gonna repossess your
grandpa it's just a hospital bill
they'll sue somebody for not paying a
hospital bill but they're not going to
repossess him
yeah you got you got snookered by your
family
yeah your next time your family knocks
on the door you need to just not open
the door
oh my gosh how long ago was this kathy
um this happened like
maybe a year and a half
i guess like yeah like a year and a half
ago at the beginning of 2020. do you
have anything in writing from your uncle
um
yeah i have like an email
okay
well um
it doesn't sound like your father is
going to be any help because he's not uh
got influence with your uncle right now
because they're already fighting am i
correct
yeah because like again so if you call
your uncle and say i look uh this is a
mess and i've you're gonna this is gonna
cost me going to college you've got to
get this money together go to the bank
and get it and send me my money i've got
to have this money what's he going to
say
i mean i tried doing that and then like
um because like the thing is like i
tried doing that and you're just like
you can go into debt i'll pay you back
my promise and like because of that
because like that was also supposed to
be like harsh because like i pay like 10
grand a year for school because of like
financial aid and they're like food and
rent on top of that and then it's just
kind of like i kind of have to hold my
tuition though
um
because of that what a butthole am i
going to die
this guy's a class a
yeah
i'm sorry um i i i don't know how to
make a person that doesn't have
character suddenly have character and
your your uncle is a scumburger
and you realize that now
yeah i like i knew that but i mean i
didn't know going into the situation
because he wasn't you know i mean i
never like your parents never dealt with
them financially
the bad news is that 21 years old you've
had this very harsh lesson
the great news is you will never have to
have this lesson again because you will
never do something like this again
because this has hurt so badly and puts
you in such a bad position
and so the you know i i hope you haven't
lost the money permanently but you
probably have because your uncle is scum
yeah
anybody that would come to a 21 year old
and ask for their college money
in order to take care of their
grandfather because you didn't go figure
out some other way to do it is scum by
definition
by definition because if the worst case
scenario is grandpa let me tell you if
he'd call me i just said grandpa can't
pay his bill call the hospital tell him
he can't pay the bill he didn't have any
money
i'd rather owe the hospital money than i
would little kathy
that it's just a matter who we're gonna
owe right
so this is just this is just garbage
it's just garbage oh my gosh kathy
so here's the thing
i you you have really two courses of
action
and none of them are good
i wish i could give you a good answer
course of action number one is calling
back and say
um
i sure hope you can pay me
i sure hope you do what you said you
were going to do i hope you're a man of
honor and a man of your word because
you're leaving me in a lurch
and hang up the phone
and then have low expectations because
he's scum that you ever get this money
and you're probably not gonna get it
okay
uh course of action number two is higher
lawyer and sue his butt
yeah i'm kind of too broke for that i
mean no you're not well
they'll take it because this looks like
fun
i'm telling you they'll take it for a
percentage and when he collects it out
of your uncle's hide
he'll uh
he'll you know but here's the thing
you'll be done with him forever but by
the way if he's my uncle i'm done with
him forever anyway
he's not gonna speak to you again won't
you sue him but i really don't care
because he ain't worth speaking to this
guy's a dirtbag
kathy he treated you like a doormat
because you're a really nice sweet
person and he thought he could get the
money took advantage of a 21 year old
young lady in college
this is making me mad as your adopted
uncle
i'm your other uncle the one that's
going to kill this one
[Laughter]
yeah it's like really bad because it's
like all of my like all of my other
uncles are like hating this one uncle
and like my mom's dad's also like really
pissed off it's like yeah you got a mess
on your dysfunctional it's not fair that
you have to deal with this so you have
two choices
just lower your expectations and don't
expect to get the money or go whole hog
and start the wrong grenades with an
attorney
that's your two choices make your
decision and then rest in peace
with whichever decision you rest in
either one's fine with me and either one
will be great i'm so sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
four
three
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host
george one of the things we've
discovered in uh
studying family businesses is that the
family business is never
any more or less toxic
than the family it's never any more less
functional or more functional than the
family is a dysfunctional family cannot
have a functional
family business
the other thing that kind of goes with
that the parallel track for that is
there's a a lot of data in our
data here over 30 years of doing this
and and even in the millionaire research
that indicates that
to the extent that
your immediate family husband and wife
and your extended family uncles
aunts
parents
so on
to the extent that
people observe
correct and reasonable
moral
boundaries with each other to the extent
that the marriage is functional to the
extent that the
interaction with the grown kids
and grandkids is functional
meaning that there's not a bunch of
manipulation lying drug use
uh
cheating whatever running around on it
whatever all this stuff to the extent
they're functional there's a high
correlation with that and the ability to
build wealth there's a high correlation
you can't build wealth
in the middle of if you're if your
family just puts the fun and dysfunction
i mean it's just very difficult to do it
it's kind of been the theme this hour
yeah
a lot of dysfunction on all these calls
and what it comes down to is you can't
give family money it just never ends up
working out for you i'd rather you be
mad at a lender and sally mae and sally
may sue you than a family member sue you
because that relationship is done
it's hard to recover but you when you
have a money problem
of any kind in the family but husband
and wife buying a van
you have a money problem
in the family
uncle wants money to pay grandpa's
medical bills when you have a money
problem
in the family
it is never the problem
it is always the symptom
of something else going on yeah
and so
the very fact that this family system in
that last call is set up in a way that a
40-something year old man can call a
21-year-old
niece
who's in college and basically steal her
college fund
and in his mind somehow that's all right
or it didn't happen this hour but we've
gotten the call before uh you know these
these parents who
take their minor children's identity and
go open a bunch of credit cards in them
and then when the minor children gets
married
as an adult and is 25 26 years old
discovers that there's a whole bunch of
credit card debt that their mom put in
their name when they were 14.
i mean
that's just that's that's criminal fraud
go to jail do not pass go
but people do it and there's this this
thing that happens in some of our
families out there
that people make this statement
well you have to take care of family
as if that statement makes all of your
miscellaneous ridiculousness
go away
like well i i just can't i have to take
care of mama i have to i mean you have
to you have to take care of family you
have to take care of him whatever it is
i mean i mean yeah i understand he stole
three cars he does cocaine he shot his
neighbor but you have to take care of
family you know but you know i mean
people are just ridiculous yeah at what
point does it just become enabling this
behavior yeah i think mom didn't save up
any money her whole life and now it's
our job to take care of her for the next
20 years and that's not mean okay it's
if you want to take care of mom and
you're able to take care of mom
that's okay but this idea that you take
this
child's
college fund
i just want to
send out the ramsey swat team for this
guy man doesn't exist by the way america
in case you're wondering oh we could we
could form it pretty quick around here
though that's right
but that that's
just makes you furious to hear stories
like that so here's the thing guys my
point of this rant is
that if you do not recognize where crazy
is in your family and every family is
crazy in it and if you think yours
doesn't it's you
so um
if you ever if you don't recognize where
crazy is in your family and learn to put
proper boundaries in place
early
in your life
and you don't teach you know let's say
you got a functional family mom and dad
are teaching a 14 year old who later
becomes a 21 year old okay uncle someone
says bad news okay he comes around you
just run him off stranger danger okay
danger danger that's right stranger no
kindergarten copper there we go good
yeah but i mean
you gotta it's yeah you have to teach
the danger of this and it it's just oh
man everyone needs to read that henry
until you fix your marriage you're not
gonna build wealth until you set
boundaries with your crazy uncle and
your your deadbeat drug son you're not
going to build wealth until you deal
with the dysfunction in your family
you're not going to build wealth you
can't get rich enough to not screw it up
with these people intersecting your life
and you just allowing them free reign
because they're just gonna take care of
family you know that kind of cr it's
just ah
do people think that they're they're
being selfish if they don't help is that
what it comes down to it's enabling from
now on and and these people the people
on the other side of it are their travel
agents for guilt trips oh that's good i
mean this guy he just oh grandpa you got
to kill your grandpa your poor old
grandpa don't you take care of your
grandpa you selfish little college
student aren't you oh it made me smack
you
unbelievable how did we know he even
used that on medical bills now i'm
second guessing this guy's integrity
going who knows what that money went
towards there's a car in the driveway
probably no it's a pickup
always a pickup isn't it it's always a
bass boat
uh wouldn't be a ski boat it'd be a
basketball yeah
you've got the ski boat that's why
you're saying that ski boat folk are
different
no they're not they're just as bad oh my
gosh i'm telling this is just but here's
the thing you can't outrun this
you have to deal with the family stuff
or you're not going to get ahead
financially you're always going to be
brought down
by the dysfunction until you've dealt
with the dysfunction or put a boundary
to the dysfunction and a fence around
you to where you can work around it
you're not you you cannot make enough
money
to out earn this
you have to deal with it so there's a
high correlation
between the ability to build wealth and
good boundaries and functional families
my grandmother used to say
when she was alive she's in a small town
she would say so-and-so comes from a
good family
now
certain members of our family would
accuse her of being uppity like she
thought they meant that meant that they
were country club folk or something
instead of the other kind of folk right
and that wasn't what she was referring
to at all when i got to know her as an
adult later what she meant was
they were a good family they had
integrity that's what she meant
and you want to you want you want to be
around a good family and there are good
families there none of them are perfect
but i mean there are some that do a
better job at this stuff than others but
oh my gosh it's almost impossible
to you know some of you have to just
become a some of you are listening in
your 19 or 21 you just have to become an
adult and set up your own life because
your whole bunch over there's nuts
you know and you just got to come over
here to the side and just look over
there and like they're like they're like
something in a psychology book every one
of them's got one of those things you
know i mean it's like unbelievable
and so you some of you just have to do
that and some of you just have to deal
with the one crazy mother-in-law
you know and some of you have to deal
with your marriage stuff and not be so
dadgum selfish and power-hungry and
entitled and all those things which
sharon and i have dealt with coming up
on 40 years
and uh now i've kind of got it down with
sharon though i have figured it out
george what's the secret i told her the
other day if she leaves i'm going with
her
how'd she take it
she might put out a restraining order at
that point
don't give her ideas
i have her convinced i'm not i'm no
genius i have her convinced well here's
what it comes down to you've got to have
boundaries and you can't change people
and so at some point you've got to just
draw the line and say listen uncle he's
just cut off we just can't be friends
with uncle you can't be friends with
grandma because it's toxic and that's a
hard thing to do today about the money
it's about the fact that you stole from
me
yes you know
it's not the money the money doesn't
matter
it's that you
mistreated a 21 year old college student
you jerk
you unbelievable jerk
i hope he's listening i hope he i hope i
get that email back that'll be a fun one
hey unk if you're listening jump on i'd
love to talk to you that'd be fun
not for you this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
four
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at 825-5225
as we talk about your boundaries your
relationships your mental health your
career your job your money and it's all
on the line right here on the ramsay
show triple eight eight two five five
two two five mary's in orlando hi mary
how are you
hey dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
good so my husband and i are in baby
step four five and six and my
child is going to college in the fall
god willing cool um we have enough in
savings to cover the cost of
her tuition
she's been offered some scholarships and
things like that but we have also
made it very clear that she's going to
have some skin in the game and we've
given her an amount that she has to pay
each year
it's minimal compared to the tuition but
it is significant for her how much uh
five thousand a year okay
now the question is
um something that my husband and i are
debating are what to do with that five
thousand if we keep it for ourselves
because we're splitting the rest of it
or do we put it in a different savings
account to give to her at the end of her
college career
pending she does well and everything
finishes school and
takes advantage of the opportunities
that we've given her you're
divorced
no no why are you splitting it
i'm sorry you said we're splitting the
rest of it
no because we're we're footing the rest
of it
i misunderstood you i'm sorry okay okay
uh you could do either one i mean it
depends on what you want to do it's your
money there's not a
not a wrong answer um it'd be cool if
you could save up the money and give it
back to her after she graduates and give
her a head start
uh but if you need it to accomplish some
goal you're hitting there's nothing
wrong with that you've you've laid out
the guidelines have you coached her and
shown her some ways she can make five
thousand dollars
yes she's on her way she she's
she's going pretty well right now with
her savings it sounded like you were
saying that she's a little worried about
making that much money
it's significant for her because
she's saving decently but once school
starts she can't keep working the way
that she's been working
could she work like 10 hours a week
she mainly works on holidays and summers
okay well she can make 5000 in the
summer i mean she's just gonna bust it
you know nannying dog sitting waiting
tables i don't know i mean you make five
grand in the summer so get out get after
it yeah but i mean i want to coach her i
don't want to just go oh
i hope good luck with that you know
she's she maybe never done this before
she doesn't know how to earn money so t
give her some entrepreneurial ideas and
you know when i was 12 i asked my dad
for money he handed me a lawnmower you
know it's like
go knock on the neighbor's door that's
where money comes from and so uh you can
do stuff like that you can walk with her
but i and i would recommend that and it
here's going to be my guess this sounds
like the first time you guys have done
this i'm going to guess and say you put
this money aside and you'll give it back
to her
but you're not obligated to do that
morally ethically financially or
anything it's just if you want to
and uh and if you're able to but if
you're on four five and six you're
working a plan i think you'll be able
yeah i mean if if you're saying hey i
can go to school debt-free and my skin
in the game is five grand a year that's
an incredible incredible deal for her
um and obviously you don't need the
money and so maybe you go hey this money
could help us pay down the house faster
which is gonna set us up in an
incredible way to be a baby step seven
and uh but either way if you hand it to
her when she graduates as a gift and go
hey this is some money you can go
upgrade your car maybe it's a down
payment on a house one day i think
that's really cool yeah yeah noble i i
have a feeling you're gonna hit your
financial goals and be able to do that
but it's not necessary it's not it's not
man it's not a bad person it's just yeah
you didn't do something wrong if you
didn't do that
it's not even a moral obligation to pay
for your child's education
you're not a bad parent if you don't pay
for it at all
it's not you know it's not there's no
law there's no standard you're a bad
parent if you don't have the
conversation at all or don't talk to
your kid honestly about where things are
at that's where i go this needs to stop
yeah you know just turning them loose in
the wild and they don't know how they
don't know what wolves look like called
student loan people
um yeah that that's dangerous i agree
with that but i'm just saying that
like i've talked to a single mom and
she's barely making ends meet just
feeding the kids is a big deal and she's
feeling all guilty because she's not
going to pay for college i'm like you're
not a bad mom you fed them
they had a roof over their head you did
a good job i mean you're a warrior lady
and christina ellis our ramsay
personality here she has an amazing
story of her mom single mom going hey i
can't pay a dime for college figure it
out and i want to help you but you got
to figure this out and she coached her
and went with her to the library and she
got a half a million dollars in
scholarships it's amazing yeah
you know that's exactly right taylor's
with us in sacramento hey taylor what's
up
hi yeah so i'm on baby step 3b and baby
step four right now i'm currently
renting and planning on buying my first
home like within two or three years when
kind of the market slows down here in
california
but i know you guys don't recommend to
purchase a manufactured home but is
there any significant difference
especially for a first-time homebuyer to
buy a brand new home that nobody's ever
lived in to an older home or any other
home type is there any kind of financial
difference or something that i should
consider when buying a house for the
first time
now you're talking about a traditionally
built new home
versus a used home
yes manufacturing homes not in this
discussion no i know you don't recommend
buying manufactured but any other home
type even condos typically what you'll
find is is that the new home prices will
be at the top of the market in a normal
real estate market we are not in a
normal anything right now
okay but in a normal world and like i
got my real estate license in 1978
so since 1978 until 24 months ago
and i don't know i don't have any idea
what's out there you know there's no way
to know today what you will run into in
this weird thing we're in right now but
in a normal world new construction will
be a higher per square foot price than
used housing
in the same neighborhood across the
street
you know that kind of a thing now you
know location will change pricing on
real estate always
uh so you know you can't
five miles away may be a big difference
you may cross two lines there that
people go oh you're on those other
tracks now you know or whatever so
that's a different thing but
not counting location if you're in the
same
general facility very close vicinity
in a normal real estate market you're
going to find new housing to be
what we call retail full retail price
and it'll be the leading edge
more expensive it doesn't mean it's not
a good buy doesn't mean it won't go up
in value doesn't mean it's not a good
idea because sometimes you're in a
growth area of the uh of the metroplex
versus a bad area or an area that's kind
of slowing down or something yeah that
kind of stuff so you know you got a lot
of a lot of factors going in but if
there are two houses on each side of the
street then yeah yeah and taylor i got a
new construction home and it is almost
2x because we live in one of the most
expensive counties the great school
system great neighborhood and so it
really does depend largely it was two it
wasn't 2x of a used house no it's brand
new as you say it's gone up to it it's
gone up to it in a little over two years
you're just fine but i mean at that time
you could have bought a used house
slightly cheaper yeah for the same
square footage but you got a nice place
got it paid off yeah it's gone up double
yeah i'll take it this is the ramsey
shop
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
five
four
three
[Music]
[Applause]
well tax season is upon us
try to contain your excitement
no one likes doing taxes especially when
you realize what the big software
companies are up to
every year these companies lure you in
saying you can file your taxes for free
and then when you're knee deep in the
filing they sucker punch you with up
charges
loan offers credit card pitches there's
a better way to do this it's called
ramsey smart tax
this is our online tax filing software
with ramsey smart tax you get all the
deductions all the forms every tax break
you deserve the best part is the price
ours is already much lower than the
leading competitor and you won't have
hidden fees and you won't get sold debt
in the process
you get a promo code right now you can
make it completely free to file your
taxes go to ramseysolutions.com
smart tax get the promo code file
without surprises
ramsey solutions dot com smart tax our
question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why they are the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings this is a wonderful
company
if you're doing window blinds you get
free samples free shipping new promos
all the time you save even more always
use the magic word the promo code ramsay
to get the best deal today's question
comes from kyle in new york he said my
wife and i make around 165 000 a year
combined i've been in my job for about
four years and i've never gotten a raise
or a promotion the company has not given
anyone a razor promotion since i've been
there that i'm aware of it's a tech
consulting company but we work with very
outdated technology i've tried for over
a year now to get a new job but my skill
set is not aligned with all the newer
technologies required by the industry if
i don't get out now i'll be stuck in
this position forever but i need about
four to six months of studying and
upskilling at this moment having a
full-time job is making this impossible
i have about forty thousand in emergency
funds and i live in a very high cost of
living area should i quit my job and
focus on updating my skills and my
resume
i don't think there's just an either or
option here that he's backed himself
into
i i personally would not quit you may
have a different opinion here dave but i
feel like both are possible even if it's
a part-time job in the tech consulting
world okay dude um
you need to let your boss know that
you're working 40 hours
not 80.
and then you need to throw a brick
through your tv
you have time to do the upskilling
i mean
just if you're working 40 hour week you
you can get your other skills
you can start doing code school at night
you can do code schools on the weekends
you write a check and get to get your
certs
um but you don't ride this horse until
it dies it's dying
this horse is he's stumbling along he's
about to die you're in you're in a tech
field that is dying if they're not
upgrading not changing not moving
you don't have the option of working
there for the rest of your life because
this company is going to fail because
they're they're they're servicing only a
technology that is going away apparently
that's what it sounds like and so you
don't have a choice you have to do this
but you're you you've added a little
drama to this
uh so turn off your television
give up vacations
no whining
go back to school at night on weekends
get down to 40 hours and do that you can
do this you can do this i'm calling bs
on the i have to quit to go to school
yeah i don't believe it i mean all right
we got tech guys around here that are
always upscaling
and they're always doing all kinds of
stuff sometimes
sometimes they do it on the clock here
sometimes they've done it while they
worked at other places to get ready to
come to work here because we use cutting
bleeding edge stuff here but um
oh man
yeah i mean it may be some long evenings
and long weekends if i don't get out now
i'll be stuck in this position forever
no you won't because they're gonna fail
you're not gonna be stuck you're gonna
be on the street
um
you know having a full-time job makes
this impossible now your your language
is just
traumatic yeah it's a lot of drama here
so impossible
stuck forever
you know and now none of these things
are true so you're gonna be okay but
dude you are going to have to sacrifice
like all your free time so going out to
eat with your little friends and stuff
no you're not going to do that for a
while because you are you're getting
re-skilled and upskilled and moving
that's the the people we meet on this
debt-free stage they find time to get
those side jobs and to find those side
hustles and it's worth it and to get
them to go to class and get the search
you know whatever it is you got to do
but it's it's there you can do this
uh albuquerque new mexico miles what's
up
hey dave uh
it's a pleasure to share the fairways
with you guys today you too how can we
help
about uh three weeks ago my car got
stolen out here
um
and uh i had comprehensive coverage
on it so uh
they're offering about a thousand less
than it's worth and then their
evaluation was only twenty dollars for
after market parts um the car had like
roof rack thinner windows like nice rims
and wheels
bluetooth stereo upgraded speakers so
just wondering if you have any tips or
guidance for trying to increase that
settlement
uh you're gonna have to provide actual
facts like receipts
and uh appraisals
okay so let's just start with the price
of the car
the car is worth this
and you can look that up on
kellybluebook.com
and you can provide them cars from
trader.com that are just like yours that
sold for this and then here are the
receipts or here's a price online price
list to buy the rims that i had the roof
rack that i had the stereo that i had
but they're not going to go i don't
think you're being fair that doesn't
work you have to give them actual facts
so what you're doing here is you're
building a court case
you're building a case that says
you are trying to sell trying to give me
less than the policy calls for which is
replacing this vehicle this vehicle
because of the roof rack the rims and
the current market value based on this
piece of data this piece of data this
piece of data this piece of data is
worth x number of dollars and you need
to give me that or more and they will
okay that makes sense do you have photos
of all the work that was done
um i i uh bought it off facebook off a
guy so i have a picture of the ad but i
don't know specifically like what uh you
know the model of the stereo was any of
that oh so you don't have the receipts
personally because you didn't do the
work
right
um
okay that's fine just yeah but go ahead
and start you know say this is the
stereo that was in it and here's what it
sells for over at xyz stereo company
okay here's the rims this tire company
sells the rims for this
and you know and here's the roof rack
and here's where here's what it cost to
buy that those are all upgrades and this
is the base car here's four cars like it
and here's kelly blue books numbers and
they all say that you're a thousand
bucks low
who's the company
uh progressives
okay they'll pay you they're not bad
you just but you do have to work in
facts
as if you're making the case
like pretend like you're going into a
court of law and you have to prove
what the car is worth not just you had a
feeling
yeah that makes sense i gotta start
researching like based off the pictures
what i think the rims are and
stuff like that so yeah so just do a
little bit of backup work and then send
you know start flooding them with emails
here's the thing too if you send them
like
like six emails or seven emails with all
kinds of different information and then
you send them one summary email and they
give them a total uh the guy starts to
realize you're not going away you're not
going to be easy to work with as a
matter of fact this guy might even get
this miles guy he might get a lawyer and
the the claims adjuster wants this off
his desk and he's going oh this is
putting effort into it uh so he's just
gonna he's just gonna go boom
be the squeaky wheel i've done this in
two different situations where i had
cars totaled or i had them
uh uh stolen
and uh in both cases i went back to them
showed them and it was one back and
forth it was not a big negotiation in
every case i got everything i was
supposed to get
the only time i didn't get the proper
amount was i was dealing with state farm
and they're notorious for not paying
their claims
so um horrible company but the uh but
everybody else i mean farm bureau i
remember i had a great transaction with
them a guy hit me and we went we showed
them exactly what it was and they went
oh yeah that's right okay and you know
they bumped it up paid wrote a check
instantly they were just you know most
of the time these guys see paying a a an
auto claim as almost pr
uh they spend all this money on
progressive on advertising they don't
want you out there running them down
yeah and they do they really honestly we
work with progressive on different
things around here all the time and they
they do a good job and contact the
seller too and see if he can provide
receipts yeah
it won't hurt but if you just show them
that you're making an effort on this
that that kind of says to them
uh i got to deal with this guy and they
go it ain't worth it and he just marks
it up and sends you a check and that's
that's the way it'll come down
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me a hundred thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
four
three
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host so a few years ago
when twitter was actually not just a
cesspool
jimmy kimmel uh would go on and read
jimmy reads mean tweets and we stole it
from him
uh and started doing you know tweets
that are mean about us because they're
fabulous
they're so fun and a lot of them are
like the high school students going
through the curriculum and stuff and uh
a lot of them are forced against their
will
and a lot of them are just you know
people can just they you know they have
digital courage these are things and you
would never say stuff like this to
somebody's face because you get your
face punched in but um
but you know people people that say
anything on the internet and it's so
cute
so we wanted to bring it back um
dave reads mean tweets and george looks
at the comments so george you're get you
get trashed on youtube yeah yeah not as
much on twitter but youtube they're big
fans of leaving me some some love okay
so you you're gonna read some of the
things said about me i guess yes all
right man i've been waiting a long time
for this dave
don't take it personal okay
all right i could take it out on you but
oh you will soon because you get to read
my comments oh there we go herman said
impulse buying an xbox feels great when
you ain't got a dave ramsey in your ear
good stuff from herman there yeah
herman's emotional
until his emotional what 13 years old
he's got to be yeah okay
money mitch said who named dave ramsey
king of finance for every christian
church is king of finance like burger
king i like that does that look like
that she'll get you a little crown get
me a little burger give me a little king
of finance crown i need a little crown
oh here's one uh username boycott delta
that's interesting after our delta rant
earlier
he said i've listened to a lot of dave
ramsey i'm convinced he quite literally
doesn't know how credit cards work he's
become a victim of his own propaganda
that's deep
that is deep
but it's all on the premise that i don't
understand how a credit card works which
is that's kind of humorous yeah the the
two sentences don't make sense together
but that's twitter for you all right
carly said if my mama doesn't stop
pushing dave ramsey on me i swear
with a little crying face
she's very upset yeah she's 19.
i don't blame her if her mom back off i
work with using me as a weapon
just why don't you push like common
sense on her instead of dave ramsey
that's better i think that i think she's
probably right we're just getting warmed
up here hey maker said dave ramsey is a
charlatan hypocrite and basic piece of
beep
you can guess what word that was
you know here's a you know think about
it
that comes up charlatan shows up a lot
after my name which is that's a ten
dollar word i know and here's the thing
i was thinking about this um i read one
of these other day and it popped into my
head how many times are you at a party
and you use the word charlatan it's zero
for i mean how many times do you have in
a sentence with normal human beings you
use the word charlatan well if they're
talking about you maybe at parties i
don't know it could be it could be it
could be it's a an anti-dave party but
um
but i mean it's not it's just not
something it comes up only on the
internet it's my point oh yeah it only
comes up when you're not real a real
person having a real conversation you
would use the word hypocrite or piece of
bleep you would do that i personally
wouldn't you wouldn't but people would
but they don't say charlatan so-and-so
is a charlatan they don't drink well if
if you're a keyboard warrior you want to
look smart wow oh yeah
and the thing is it had to it had a
spell check
yeah because you couldn't spell it no
okay they probably started with an s and
got it wrong yeah all right brian moody
said dave ramsey is good for people to
clean up a financial mess and get their
house in order he started out nice
but wealthy people don't baby step
okay so the
45
millionaires we've talked to on the air
this year we started tracking
millionaires we talked to on the air
so since january one on this show we've
talked to 45 millionaires
i guess they would beg to differ he has
a different definition of millionaires
maybe or wealthy yeah
wealthy people there we go kyle henkel
said i think dave ramsey financial
advise is cringy cringy there's a lot of
misspellings there but you know what
they're yeah
[Laughter]
but wait but you know what i yeah uh it
is cringey it's so cringe dave dead free
oh it is it's cringy because it like it
says
ooh you have to sacrifice to win that is
cringy that's so cringe no it is i mean
it's like that's kind of like ugh i kind
of i kind of agree with him get with the
times dave people don't want to hear
that
all right addy said proud owner of a new
tacoma if dave ramsey found out he'd
probably 360 no scope me
i had to look this one up dave this is a
call of duty reference in which a player
spins around with
the rifle and shoots with no scope
killing their target let me help you
with this he didn't really because it's
not a real rifle it's on a video game
call of duty they're assuming that you
are playing call of duty and well yeah
so
so i'm gonna
i'm gonna
fake kill him on a fake game is that
that's how the metaverse works that's
what happens if you buy a tacoma i fake
kill you on a fake game you just
described them at a verse there you
finally got it i finally got it okay
uh jen said in my head i mixed up dave
ramsey and gordon ramsay and really
thought all this time that gordon ramsay
was giving financial advice in addition
to this the clip of gordon ramsay
somebody said who's dave ramsey he's
like bleep bleep bleep bleep bleep dave
rosie please please yes it's hilarious
they're at the grocery store and gordon
ramsay's helping them shop and the guy
accidentally says dave ramsey instead of
gordon and he goes i'm not bleeping dave
ramsey it was a great clip that's so
funny he's he's a great last one for you
also cool kid with uh a k and a k said
dave ramsey is a coke head and then
parentheses this is libel spelled wrong
actually he spelled it out it's liberal
sorry spelled it but it's live wow well
clear the air dave are you a coke head
and is that liable
i
i hadn't had a coke in a long time i
quit drinking coke
he did got a big head
does that count like a big basketball
head that counts
does that count i feel like if you if
you were a cokehead we'd have a very
different shell on our hands
well yeah because the caffeine in
coca-cola will that's what lights you up
that's so true
all right dave my turn i get a few
boomers i don't have as many all right
david says uh george gives worthless
advice the absolute worst of all ramsey
personalities yikes george what's scary
is i'm just giving the advice you would
have given so what does that say about
you
oh my goodness
yeah since they all kind of say the same
thing but with different tones that's
hurtful yeah that's true all right
janelle and she says this like once a
week this is normal for george chanel
this is janelle's like she's like head
of your anti-fan club hey i'll take it
any pr is good pr they say george has
the charisma of a wet sock
sorry man at least she apologized right
after yeah that's just passive
aggressive but yeah but it is a wet sock
no disrespect no disrespect right after
they disrespect you that's always like
throwing that on the end because it
negates it yeah wouldn't a dry sock have
less charisma
i feel like if something's dry it has
even less i don't know janelle i don't
know how you measure saw charisma no i
don't know what the measure on soccer is
all right who is the nerd in glasses
giving advice well we both have glasses
on is he new or something
oh boy no i've actually lost weight i
look about the thing you look great dave
and i don't think you're a nerd i think
you're just intellectual does does
dahloney wear glasses he doesn't wear
glasses no i'm not just me and you
holding down me
yeah because rachel had glasses before
she got like that the glass the eye
thing done oh yeah and it looked like
coke bottle bottoms i mean she looked
like the kid there was a guy on office
space you remember they need the stapler
oh yeah that's what her glasses we both
have terrible uh eyesight me and rachel
here's the thing people say is he new or
something and i've been here nine years
guys get a clue
are you new
whatever george came off as a little rat
bag at first but he's grown on me
he's consistent and he's logical oh
that's a comment i thought you were just
telling me
i said james said this james smith not
james
sir james not james in the booth james
smith said this and which is probably
i'm sure his real name so it started
what is a rat bag i don't know it just
sounds like a bag of rats it's a bag of
rats i guess
came off as little i guess a little
condescending know-it-all little you
know punchable phase type guy well yeah
but i mean
he could have just said a little rat i
don't know what a bag of rats is i don't
know but at least he he then went he's
he's grown on me he's consistent he's
logical so i'll take that
he's a he's a logical consistent little
ratbag trying to end it on a positive
note for you thank you james
this is just james actually letting us
know how he feels about us and he just
changes the names james wrote always
that's cruel man
kelly wrote some of them i know she did
here's my worry dave people are now
going to write in specifically hope
trying to get on the show hoping to get
other their mean tweet on the show so
we're never doing this again
because we're thin skinned and our
feelings are hurt
and i'm gonna have to go home and
cry
because you
three of you don't like me on the
internet
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
four
three
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five i don't
know why anyone would want our advice
after that last segment but we're gonna
give it to you anyway lauren is with us
in oklahoma city hi lauren welcome to
the ramsay show
hi there how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
just a quick question on what your ideas
opinions input is on
uh following a passion job versus
financial security stability uh
essentially chasing the money i'm 42
years old i have a double income with my
wife
we have two kids
uh very little debt about 50 000 total
debt including a vehicle and medical
debts
i
just started a couple months ago going
back to school
to become to become a teacher
uh
wow this will introduce new debt why uh
essentially to follow a passion i
started school
uh i graduated high school and your
passion is to be a teacher in the
classroom or to teach yep or to teach to
be a teacher in a classroom because i'm
a teacher
okay but i didn't take a pay cut
right right essentially this hopefully
would give me
a better stability and job
not necessarily higher income though it
would be a
bump
based on where i teach and whatnot
but uh yeah what do you make now
roughly 35.
and what would you make in the classroom
uh about 45 to 60. if you're going to
make multiple again depending on where i
teach yeah you're going to make more
than you make now
right i thought you were saying you
would have to go down an income to work
your passion no no no it would it would
it would be a bump in income oh okay why
would you not do it yeah
it would it would introduce more debt oh
we'll just go get your teaching
certificate without going into debt pay
cash for it
uh a little tough no it's not
it's called work lord the way you
phrased up your debt initially you said
oh we just have a little bit of debt
just 50 grand so it tells me you're
broke
how is it a little debt if you can't
afford to cash flow school because of it
right we we essentially live paycheck to
paycheck um
uh we have
what's your wife what's your wife work
what's that what's your wife make
about 33 000. okay so you have a
68 000 household income which is the
average household income in america
how much is your car payment
uh for
400 or 398 a month sell your car and we
have about 22 000
left on the loan yeah show your car
you're not gonna do that i could tell by
the way you answered that
see here's the thing you've got it in
your head that you get to do all of
these things at once keep a car you
can't afford go get a degree you can't
afford
what meanwhile making the excuse of we
live paycheck to paycheck and that's an
excuse it's not a fact
right sell your stinking car get three
extra jobs go to the community college
and get your teaching certificate and
pay cash for your teaching certificate
and live your dream with no additional
debt
by the way when you sell your car cut
your debt in half
right that would
something for you to think about dude i
don't know if you're going to do it or
not because i think you got this all
figured out in your head that you want
to go be normal the way you're
describing is normal but i'll help you
with this normal sucks
you're getting ready to keep a 22 000
car you can't afford and go get a degree
and put another 25 or 30 000 on top of
this and get a 10 000 bump and you're
gonna then you're gonna wind the
teachers don't make enough
what i'm hearing is we're already 50
grand in debt what's another 20 30 40 to
get this well it's just this mindset
that this is normal and it's it's the
only way to do it well it's not the only
way to do it i'll guarantee you you can
work overtime you can work extra jobs
and you can go to the cheapest possible
local university
community college whatever it is you got
to do to finish up your work to get your
teaching certificate and i want you to
go be a teacher i just don't want you to
be dumb about it
because i it's just going to cost you
it's going to cost you a decade of your
life doing this wrong and really let's
do this stupid car it has to do with you
not being willing to sacrifice and dial
this down instead you're just kind of
going the easy way and the easy way is
always not the easy way it's always the
hard way and the truth is even with this
bump in income you're going to be broke
again you're not going to fix the
problem there you go because you've gone
up in debt enough that it sucks up every
bit of that new income and so all the
joy from this is going to be gone
audrey's with us in albuquerque new
mexico hey audrey how are you
hey i'm doing well good afternoon good
afternoon how can we help all right yeah
so my husband is 16 years military and
five years ago we decided to live
minimally so we can stop living paycheck
to paycheck and be able to
save up enough to cash flow everything
wow after return
after it was a big goal
after returning from an overseas tour
last year
we did what we never dreamed we can do
we paid cash for a seven a second
vehicle and we paid cash for our home
whoa
way to go
well thank you for your service both of
you and i'm so proud of you well done
thank you for your support we seriously
never thought we'd ever be in a place
like this so
my question is we move every two to
three years in the military and is it
okay if we can continue to purchase cash
for a home i mean obviously they sent us
to california that probably won't happen
but
um we want to continue to pay cash for a
home at every assignment
or should we rent and just focusing on
investing which we've only started doing
last year
probably some of both depending on where
you're where you're stationed
okay okay so let me kind of give lay
this out for you yes if you can pay cash
and you want to buy that's fine
we generally recommend to our our
brothers and sisters in the military
that they not purchase and here's why
usually during a two year or three year
stay the house does not go up enough in
value
to cover the cost of selling it
and you end up losing money from the
purchase to the resale
great and if you're doing that with cash
that's going to hurt ouchy
okay okay now the way you can there's a
couple things you can do to get ready to
determine this when you once you know
where you're going to be stationed next
time once you know where the move is all
right you hey you're gonna put yours on
the market and sell it for sure no
question about that don't leave it okay
so you got that money in your hand and
then you start shopping in the other
area here's the two numbers that will
tell you
um if you if you buy or not
okay
now
the military markets you've been in 16
years so you already know this but let
me just review with you okay
some of these uh bases are in
areas where the entire economy is the
military it's a small town
yeah that's right and so the real estate
economy is driven by people like you
coming and going coming and going coming
and going consequently sometimes the
houses don't escalate as much because
there's always a supply always an
inventory of them for sale
yes and so you do a lot of times in a
small town generally military economy
you're not going to do as well but
anyway here's the numbers you look for
ask the real estate agent to
to run a study off the mls statistics
for you that tells you two things within
a five mile radius of the house you're
looking at buying
what is the average appreciation for the
past five years
per year how much is it going up per
year
okay if you're gonna be there three
years and it goes up two percent a year
average
you're going to lose money when you
resale
because real estate commissions are six
and closing costs you're gonna you know
it's gonna be a 10 out of pocket to
resale and so if you don't make more
than 10 increase in value during the
time you're there
then you're going to lose money you
follow me
yes so you know how much is the average
appreciation and am i going to be here
long enough to where i make money on
this rather than lose money that's thing
one
the number the second statistic is dom
average days on the market
what is it houses within a five mile
radius how quickly do they sell when
they go on the market
in some of these slow markets like i was
talking to about a while ago now right
now it's weird out there you can sell
anything in a lot of places but
if the market out there is um
yeah there we go if the market out there
it is slow and it says 270 days on the
market is the average time to sell a
house that's nine months you don't buy
there because that means you're gonna
get stuck in the thing
but if the average days on the market's
27 days that's a hot market oh by the
way where you find a slow a low days on
the market quick sale you're usually
going to see higher appreciation rates
it's a hot market
by definition so that tells you if you
can it can and should buy in there
that's the plan
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host we're talking about your life
and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your relationships
your careers your money your job your
boundaries
we talk about all of it here triple
eight eight two five five two two five
misty's with us in indianapolis hi misty
how are you
i'm great thank you guys so much for
taking my call sure what's our how can
we help
so i'm calling about my son's school
loan um
when i was first learning about the baby
steps he was getting ready to go to
college he did take out a small loan
against my advice
i did not co-sign for it
but
i did say
that i would pay it back when it came
time to be due
because i felt bad because i had not
done anything for his college i hadn't
prepared for college at all for him
i was expecting it to be in four years
and i would be done with the baby steps
by then
um
unfortunately the pandemic hit he took a
semester off and never returned back to
school
so in the meantime this loan company had
my bank account number because they had
said if i paid a small amount each month
it would be better in the end
so they started automatically taking
payments out
and then
within it was a year ago he ran away
from home
which he is an adult but i now have
almost no contact with him
so i also have no ability to see what
the loan amount is what's left how much
to pay
so my question is since i said i would
pay initially should i keep paying it or
since he left and pretty much didn't
follow what i thought was going to
happen what was the balance i
it was a 12 000 loan okay what do you
make
uh right now i have a really good salary
um i make
this past year i made 140 000. so it's
nothing for me to pay it
as of right now why are you a stranger
why is he not speaking to you
i'm not quite sure he told me i have
seen him about three times in the last
year he told me it was because i was too
manipulative
i believe um that his father had gotten
into his head and said some things
because i'm actually not on quite the
pushover
um
i'm not yeah i'm not really sure he just
said he needed to be off on his own
which is fine i i want him to be on his
own but he's not
he's not working he's not going to
school he just sits at his dad's house
and has no relationship with me or
anyone else in my family
i'm sorry
that's hard
so misty do you feel like the dad isn't
enabling him to just sit around all day
and putting thoughts in his head about
you
yeah um yes and no it's actually his
grandma that's the enabler um his dad
never had a job until
our son was 17 years old because his mom
would pay for everything she paid all
the child support she paid
i mean my son would make a christmas
list and she'd buy every single thing on
it
um he still lives with her
you're not supposed to do that 40 years
old
[Laughter]
i'm asking for a friend
[Laughter]
we had a lot of problems when we were
together the short time we were together
he was he had pulled me away from all my
friends and family very emotional um
emotionally
so how long how long ago did you all
divorce
oh um he was our son was one so okay so
so you raised this boy
all his life
yeah and so you've spoken into his life
a lot more than anybody else has he's
got that down inside of him
yes and he'll come back around
thank you
yeah you've made more deposits in his
bank than they have
in who he is
there's more of you in him
and so he's going to come back around
um
there's nothing wrong with
either answer here there's not a you
don't have a moral thing you have to do
or certainly don't have a legal thing
you could simply cut you can simply let
him know
uh until you and i are in a relationship
i am not going to pay your loan
okay you could tell him that and then
just cut the cut the draft off block it
and don't let him take money out of your
account and then it'll just sit there
and build until his grandmother pays it
or he pays it or whatever right yeah and
there's nothing wrong with that at all
nothing wrong with that okay uh it
really he probably doesn't care because
he's probably not gonna do anything
about it right now
exactly he'll just roll his eyes and go
mom's trying to you know jerk my chain
okay
nothing wrong with that
the other option of course is
just to say you know what
it's twelve thousand bucks screw it i'm
just gonna pay it
i'm gonna write a check be done with it
and um and i'm never gonna bring it up
again
if you're gonna pay it you cannot use it
as leverage ever
you just gotta let it go that's an act
of forgiveness
on your part
and you're just gonna go
not not not like you're trying to buy
his love or you're trying to win him
back
you're never gonna bring it up again you
it's not leverage
if you're going to use it as leverage
don't pay it off
okay okay because that's not good for
you to sit the steward with that okay
so that's just old man ramsey talking
okay so that's just nothing to do with
money is just
let him go let the let the whole thing
go and when he comes back around someday
he'll go oh mom whatever happened with
that loan i just paid it don't worry
about it
yeah and just don't bring it up
because you don't want to feed into this
narrative of you being manipulative
okay so and honestly
um
i'm a little softer in my old age
i probably would do option two
yeah is what dave ramsey would probably
do today
i'd probably just pay it not because i'm
trying to win their love back not
because i'm trying to get attention
because i'm not going to bring it up but
because if you're going to do all that
you're going to be disappointed because
he's not going to come back around he's
not going to like you because of this
he's not gonna none of that's gonna work
okay but just to let him go let's set
him free
and then he'll swoop back around
and it it
every day that he doesn't is painful for
you but he'll come back around mom
thank you
and i think you paying this off is going
to set you free and even the other way
yeah because i think i think every time
you pay it you get mad again
[Laughter]
i would it would piss me off like every
month for a few minutes i gotta reset my
brain now
i'm gonna kill the lord i'm gonna kill
him i'm gonna kill his father i'm gonna
kill my ex-mother-in-law i'm gonna kill
all of them okay now i gotta have my
coffee and i'm gonna work okay
[Laughter]
oh you did that did you okay
yeah this is worth twelve thousand
dollars to not have this conversation in
your head every month
yeah it is yeah you're right
set yourself free and miss do you still
have access to all these accounts you
were saying something earlier about no
he no i do not she can't get it but well
how are you going to pay it off that's
what i'm wondering
i don't know i mean
yes you have to contact the student loan
servicer why don't you call them and
just say i know you can't tell me the
amount but um
but i need you to draft the amount out
of my account this month to pay it off
can you do that
okay i'll try that and then make sure
there's 15 000 bucks laying in there so
that you're ready
oh
man that's a hard one yeah that's so
hard
now
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
three
[Music]
so
[Music]
well sadly one of the things you hear on
this show every so often is
stress and anxiety
all kinds of different things certainly
around money
but people have experienced all kinds of
anxiety and loneliness and stress lately
here's the good news our own ramsay
personality dr john deloney has a brand
new book out i am so excited we actually
got them in today i got to hold one of
them in my hands it is it's a great book
now of course i read the manuscript
months ago as we were developing the
book but uh it comes out in april it's
on pre-sale right now it's called own
your past change your future it's
selling fast everybody wants and needs
to know about dr loney's dr deloney's
not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
and you're in for a treat when you eat
read this you're going to laugh you're
going to cry you're going to be
challenged i did i was
and you'll be transformed
how to deal with different types of
trauma how to get connected into a
community and the steps that you take to
change your thoughts and actions yes you
can own your past and change your future
so when you pre-order today you'll get
free bonus items includes a month of
free one-on-one therapy weekly therapy
through our partners at better help who
does this this is a great bargain
all for just pre-ordering a 20 book oh
and you get the e-book and the audiobook
as well read by the author
so check it out
own your past change your future it's on
pre-sale right now twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com
so george the scams are up i'm seeing on
this article that our producer james
handed us
on the uh
dad blame student loans the federal
trade commission's warning about an
increase in these scams yeah this is bad
and uh of course they're preying on
people's confusion and people are
getting stressed about student loan
pause being unpaused and so they're
saying the federal government put
federal student loan payments on pause
during the pandemic with that pause
expiring people are anxious and the
scammers are swooping in they're
promising to reduce payments or even
cancel student debt entirely
if you give them your credit card number
they use social media text messages
phone calls and the scripts are
convincing some of them even sound like
they're coming from this hi this is shay
with sla servicing we're in the process
of pre-enrollment for all loan
forgiveness it's going to be a bit more
challenging as deadlines come and so
we'll need your credit card to be able
to get this you'd be a great scammer
dave i'll tell you what this is the
radio voice on to do that right there we
go
so that's so scummy so i want to give
people some quick tips and tools to
avoid getting scammed number one if a
student loan servicer calls you it's
probably a scam generally these people
don't work that hard they're not calling
you they've got better things to do so
some red flags you got to look out for
if they're asking you for your username
and password if they're asking you for
banking information if you've already
given your payment information call your
bank put a hold on that account
immediately so they can't get any more
money you can report all this stuff to
the federal trade commission the the
consumer financial protection bureau
your state attorney general
don't fall for this stuff yeah
let me just tell you it's a good rule
here here's a basic thing on scam
avoidance and you've done a lot of this
stuff on fine print
if someone that you already are doing
business with like you have a student
loan
you have a credit card you shouldn't but
you have a debit card you have a credit
card you have a what you you have an irs
account and they call you up and say
this is joe with the irs to verify that
we're talking with the right person
would you please give us your social
security number the irs never does that
they already have your social security
number they don't need to ask you
your bank does not we need to verify
would you give us your your uh your
credit card number
no
i won't you should already have that if
i already am doing business with you
know we need your we need to verify your
bank information we're with uh sallie
mae
no you should probably already have my
bank information and so they'll never
ask that kind of stuff so this just this
should the red flag should go off the
siren should go off the bpp people be
going off when you hear that i just
don't answer phone calls these days
they're usually no good but here's what
you can i got a call from russia tell me
about my stoop my extended warranty your
car's extended warranty dave yeah i
don't think they're worried about that
right now they got bigger problems but
here's the thing
you said russia oh yeah on my phone i
got that too are we getting the same
call yeah wow well here's a good rule of
thumb a lot of these places can spoof
the exact number they can spoof the
sheriff's office they can spoof the irs
number so even if you get a call and it
says it's the same number as the irs go
to the irs website check the phone
number and you call them back
because that way you avoid running into
that situation and so like
we had a a couple of people on get
scammed or almost get scammed or
whatever here
uh that was a call from the local
sheriff's department and when you called
their number back that they left
it was the exact recording they had
taken a recording from the sheriff's
department and put it over there with
the same phone tree and everything yeah
but if you call the sheriff's department
they would say oh no there's a scam
going around don't talk to those people
don't go over there and pay parking fees
that you don't know don't go over there
and you know there's not an arrest
warrant out for you you know that kind
of stuff so you gotta you gotta hang up
and call back
directly not the number the scammer
gives you but the actual number that you
have
and then you'll find out oh that really
wasn't a real person that was shay is in
somewhere
in some slavic company country or
whatever oh my gosh yeah don't fall for
this stuff guys and i know people are
stressed and when you're stressed it can
get you to be panicked and you start
making poor decisions well there's two
times people get scammed okay
when you're afraid and desperate and
when you're greedy
like if you think you're gonna get
something free and easy people fall for
that one too
and so student loan forgiveness is the
free and easy thing
yeah they go oh well forgive your
student loans but you need to send us
200 to verify yeah that's what's not or
just i just need your credit card number
so we can get the account set up to get
this going and i'm like oh if you're
going to forgive it why do you need the
number
and
yeah if it seems too good to be true
it's too it is don't do it yeah
there you go good stuff that's happening
it's happening out there right this
second and it usually comes with irs
stuff or the other ones that come up are
people collecting uh money for charities
for um war-torn countries and all kinds
of stuff yeah it's a problem mark is
with us mark is in houston texas hey
mark how are you
good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
all right uh i got a question appreciate
y'all taking my call
um
so i have the six hundred thousand
twenty year term life insurance policy i
have a seven-year-old son
who lives with uh me and my wife my
current wife
his mom is uh were uh divorced and
she if i pass he goes with her so
my question is how should i spit up or
should i spit up
my life insurance policy
like how do i take care of my wife if i
pass and my son
does that make sense yeah
uh well you can have the beneficiary be
a percentage and you can say 50 to your
current wife 50 to your son okay now i
personally if i were in your situation
would not leave the money to your son
with your ex-wife in charge
that just brings of all kinds of bad
medicine to me so i would set up a uh
a trust a family trust that is formed
upon your death and the money is funded
into that trust so the beneficiary for
your son is
sons family trust whatever you name it
right you name it okay give it a little
name and you set up a little trust and
it's formed upon your death the trust
never happens if you don't die
until you know if you don't die while
he's a minor okay if he when he's a
grown person you'll just leave him the
money if you want to or not
but uh when he's a kid you're going to
leave some money for his to care for him
and you can even you can set whoever you
want up as the trustee to manage it your
brother your mother your current wife
whoever you want to leave to make sure
the money is distributed to your child
to take care of your child out of the
trust but i would not just leave 300 000
bucks to the ex-wife to manage
yeah
yeah that just sounds like a bad and if
you leave it to the kid
she's going to be managing it because
she's the guardian
so don't leave it to the kid
leave it to a trust to take care of the
kid and the trustee make sure that money
is managed according to the trust and so
you can set it up to be however you want
to do it you can do 50 50 60 40. you can
say 400 thousand two hundred thousand
you can call it whatever you wanna do
i don't care uh whichever way you wanna
do it um
and but a beneficiary a primary
beneficiary can be more than one entity
by percentages or by amounts
and for a minor child i recommend family
trust yeah good reminder there that
putting a seven-year-old as the
beneficiary isn't going to work because
they can't accept that money at seven
years old you have to be it goes into
their name but the guardian would be in
charge of it yeah and that would be the
x
yikes
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
dot
blinds.com
three
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're glad you are
here david is in jacksonville hi david
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave and uh george how you all doing
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
i got a question so i wanted to see what
you would do if you were in my shoes uh
um
i have a 34 000 student loan uh we're
following the baby steps i call it baby
step 2.5 but actually we're in three
um i have about eleven thousand uh an
emergency fund
and i'm on a loan forgiveness program
that after 10 years for public service
for the state
the
last of the loan is forgiven so that
would give me about 17 000 i only have
five more years to pay on it should i
just continue making the minimal
payments on that and just have the last
step of forgiving or be able if i have
the ability now to go ahead and pay the
thing you know get it paid off here
probably the next year or two
the program that you're engaged in has
been has proven to be an absolute scam
here's the actual numbers on the public
service loan forgiveness program
so far 726
811 people have applied for what you're
applying for
seven hundred thousand people
to date eight thousand have been granted
it one percent
okay that's a no-brainer
yeah i mean if if this was happening six
months from now when you were about done
with it i'd say all right let's ride it
out but five years from now it's a long
time when you can pay this thing off in
a year and move on with your life and be
in a totally different place financially
instead of hoping
and putting your hope in someone else's
control yeah this is one of the times
that the government completely lied
um has it happened before dave you said
one of the times i said one of the times
wow one of the many times okay of course
they've lied but they uh this this this
is a complete and utter scam there are
three types of student loan forgiveness
um
and this is the type that people sign up
for and that has not worked now student
loan forgiveness in the event of
disability
is actually occurring
student loan forgiveness uh when the you
you know take a like a tech school and
the tech school scams you and closes
down truck driving school or whatever
that loan is forgiven those are forgiven
and when you die student loans are
forgiven
but uh uh and so those types of loans
have that that type of forgiveness
program has actually worked but the uh
public student loan forgiveness program
is an abs public service loan
forgiveness program is an absolute
horrid scam
1.16
of the people who have signed up for it
and counted on it have actually gotten
it it's a 99 fail rate wow yeah we did a
deep dive on that very specific topic on
the borrowed future podcast in episode
six don't bank on student loan
forgiveness it's about 40 minutes long
and it's worth the listen david if you
need some encouragement to go ahead and
pay these loans off and move on with
your life yeah it's the borrow future is
the documentary that we put out on
student loans but we also before we did
that put out an eight series uh podcast
that you were the host of yeah it was
eye-opening yeah so borrowed future if
you want to learn about what's really
going on in the student loan world it is
it's really a dark dark world yeah i
mean it's it's nasty there's about a
thousand villains you can point at in
the story too many too many good story
needs one maybe two villains but this
one has
everything from congress to banks to
parents and guidance counselors and
student loan companies
i could keep going colleges i mean
universities yeah i mean it's just like
there's a villain on every corner braden
is in phoenix arizona hi braden how are
you
hey george hey dave i'm good how are you
guys better than we deserve man what's
up
awesome hallelujah um
so i kind of i'm in the stage of my life
where i've never been this busy a lot of
moving parts um my fiance and i are
getting married a month from today yay
yeah thank you so much yeah i'm so
excited we're excited
um
we come from a little bit different um
financial background we're both new in
our careers we both have student loans
uh she's currently in a car release
that's up in december we don't live
together obviously we're waiting to get
married and i just i i just finished the
total money maker i'm excited about her
makeover sorry i'm a little nervous okay
you're fine you're doing good
um we just
i just i'm excited i'm fired up i just
don't know how to move about
um setting the right kind of money aside
for the car purchase that she's going to
need that we're going to need to make
later this year and as well as
how to
how to get started in this plan together
and how to get us both on the same page
with um the aspect of being excited and
ready to make sacrifices if that makes
sense have you talked about all this
yeah yeah yeah we talked about it but
you feel like you're philosophically
aligned but the details aren't is all
you're missing
yeah
yeah that wasn't convincing for example
i guess for example
you know
she's thinking i tell her let's let's
sell some stuff save and hibernate and
get rid of our college debt and she's
thinking let's do a road trip in this
month and let's go out and put some
money aside this is the definition of
not being aligned philosophically
i mean
yeah i guess you're right um
i mean i guess the fact that she's gonna
carve these kind of is a little bit
different than i would do yeah well not
that it's just it's it's not about where
you are it's about what you're gonna do
about where you are you want to sell
some stuff get out of debt pile up some
cash to buy her a car she wants to go on
a road trip
so this is what we're going to do about
where we are where we are is one thing
but what we're going to do about it is
what's scary and you are on polar
opposites on that
are you guys doing any pre-marriage
counseling
we are we are we're almost towards the
end of it right now but i guess we
haven't probably financed it yet yeah
you need to well brandon i want to do
you a favor i want to give you a wedding
gift i'm going to give you one year to
ramsay plus and it will give you access
to all the videos in financial peace
university both of you and you have to
do it together that's the promise you're
going to make me you're going to build
your first budget together with every
dollar plus and you're gonna put all
your income all the expenses and we're
gonna get some goals on paper about what
we're gonna do as a couple we with both
of our money once we combine our income
so if that doesn't get on the same page
there's gonna be some deeper issues here
maybe some some more counseling but i
think if you get her excited about what
the future could look like without debt
maybe she'd be okay putting off the road
trip until we pay off our loans and we
use that to celebrate yeah the answer is
not read the total money makeover hey
let's sell your car no that dude that
doesn't usually go well
so um
instead we go all right well let's look
at our future together and what's the
best way to get there
and so you're if you've got if you're
getting good pre-in-depth pre-marriage
counseling they're going to go there and
they should have already before one
month from the wedding honestly but um
dig into that you guys start talking
about this because here's the thing
and here's how you can couch it to her
the number one cause
of divorce in north america today the
number one thing couples fight about
money and money problems
getting if you get on the same page
about money
right now
you're gonna save yourself heartache in
the area that is the number one problem
in marriage that's pretty cool if you
can get rid of the number one problem
then all that's left are the other ones
yes sir
that's a big deal i mean if the number
one
way that you know that
whatever that you did something you
always just go do the number get get
that one out of the way so you guys get
on the same page take the take the uh
subscription and the two of you start
watching some of the videos instead of
binge watching netflix and um
start going through financial peace
university if you can find a church in
your area that's teaching it get in the
class and you can go back through it as
many times as you want during this year
we're going to give you a one-year
subscription as a wedding gift but
please don't do it by yourself and then
go in and try to explain to her
it's gonna get you that's gonna get you
murdered dave says is to the the worst
words in a marriage yeah and well and i
just learned this and so i'm gonna tell
you where you're stupid that's not a
good plan okay no no no no get her with
you make this her idea and your idea and
the two of us together are gonna tackle
the world you need a shared vision you
need common language and that's why
financial peace university is so
powerful it's not magical content it
just gets you on the same page where you
can talk about things and understand
each other and then do some math and go
here's what we're spending in interest
that we're throwing away towards lenders
that could have gone towards the next
road trip
so use all of those things in
combination and see if that has her turn
a corner yeah and don't bring us up
again until you're watching the stuff
don't say what dave said i read this
book that's just suicide it doesn't work
so congratulations we're excited for you
man
kelly's going to pick up we're going to
get you guys signed up for this as our
gift
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey
[Music]
our scripture today first peter 3 15 but
in your hearts revere christ as lord
always be prepared to give an answer to
everyone who asks you to give the reason
for the hope that you have
but do this with gentleness and respect
jim rohn says if you say something and
back it up with your actions you will
provide the proof for people who are
listening to you and they will much more
willingly follow your lead
amen
open phones this hour george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money amber is with us in uh san
francisco hi amber how are you
hi i'm good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
um okay so i had a question that's a
little bit complicated you would have to
know a little bit of my background to
like know where i'm coming from
basically i'm getting kicked out of my
grandmother's house in a month
not because of anything i've done
i pay rent and everything she just wants
her own house to herself uh
going you know my parents moved up to
idaho all the way up in monarch ferry
uh in november
and uh like our uh our relationship is
not there
uh basically when i was 12 they put me
to work full-time uh
before their company construction
company for absolutely no pay up until i
was 20
and i got injured and i said that's it
i'm done
like
i'm an adult
they knew that the
expenses weren't going to go under their
names because i was an adult so i racked
up medical bills trying to get to
basically trying to get
better
so i have two jobs right now
which is in and out in starbucks and uh
i just got injured on chico
and like i have all this financial
pressure on me right now and i'm not
exactly sure
what to do how old are you i've
i'm 23 now
okay what part of san francisco are you
in
uh i am on the
east part of san francisco okay living
with my grandmother yeah but for only
for one more month and you work at
starbucks
and in and out starbucks and where in
and out burger in and out yeah okay
all right
all right
so um
my question was because i bought two of
your books it was like how can i
basically how can i do more and save
more with the situation that i have
right now
well um
this sounds very lonely to me
and and
and a little scary you're probably
pretty scared aren't you
yeah
very much so
okay
well a couple of observations that are
um
obvious but i'm just going to say them
out loud so we're all dealing with the
same hand of cards here one you don't
make much money because your jobs suck
two
uh you live in one of the most expensive
cities in the world
is that fair
correct okay yeah that's very fair so um
one of the things i'm going to want to
do mathematically is to help adjust that
some way or another
uh do you have relatives that are uh
friendly not that you live with but that
would give you some emotional support
in any other area of the country
um i do have two brothers living here
but one of them is actually going to go
move up near my parents and take a job
there i
i refuse to move up north because like
at 23 i received my first paycheck ever
i'm i i i'm not asking you to move in
with your parents it wasn't what i was
suggesting
i'm just trying to get some emotional
support around you and somebody to walk
with you because what you're describing
to me is terrifying
yeah um
i could
the only closest thing that i have right
now
is my uh
my uncles
that lived here and they all lived there
your brother your uncle your grandmother
yes my brother my uncle and my
grandmother and your parents and your
other brother moved to idaho okay
all right correct
well here's what i would tell you to do
you need community um
and if um
if you were my long-lost niece and you
called me uh i would say let's get you
into a good church where you can get
some people around you that love you and
walk with you and get some quality
humans in your life
that are walking with you
because you're processing all the pain
of your childhood and the distrust of
your parents
um but with number one you need a great
career track right now you're you're
trying to just survive as a barista and
barista jobs are not set up for survival
they're set up for supplement at best
and so we need to get a good job that
makes a lot more money and so let's
start talking about new career new job
full-time jobs that aren't fast food
as soon as possible making more money
and then obviously you've got to look
for a place to live don't you
yes i've been looking out of state and
just having friends feel like hey
can you lend me some money that way i
can make it i'll pay you back when i'm
actually set up because california i
can't do it okay so you're thinking of
leaving california
corrected okay so expensive do you have
you do you have any money at all
i have about
1500 in savings right now okay good good
okay because you can go work those two
types of jobs in other cities in america
and it change
change your living situation severely
um so um
but you know being a nanny walking dogs
you'll make more than you're making now
okay um you know doing anything that
that moves the needle on the money piece
that's legal and moral and doesn't put
you in harm's way
um
is what we've got to look at and yeah
i'm i'm
really up for you leaving san fran just
because it's so stinking expensive
and it doesn't sound like you got an
emotional support system there anyway
and so i'm gonna pick out a city and i'm
gonna move and make it happen and no you
don't need to borrow a bunch of money
and you don't even need to take a whole
bunch of uh personal items with you you
got a car
no i do not
do you have a driver's license
unfortunately i do not okay why
i had left there uh
i had left their household back in
november october it was kind of a rough
situation so i said i'm gonna go make it
on my own because i have
nothing to my name
so have you ever driven a car
i have my brother and i have practice
but
i have been out
with an injury and i've been working all
the time i've been just working putting
my head down and working non-stop
i'm so sorry amber well it sounds like
there's a lot of trauma that you haven't
dealt with that i think needs to be a
part of this equation as you move and
get new jobs i think there's a lot here
that you've got to unpack with a great
counselor a great therapist to walk with
you and i also want to send you a copy
of ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose to help you get on that path to
a career that you love making great
money doing it so that we can turn the
situation around so i'll have kelly pick
up so if i'm you i'm getting out of
yellowpad and i'm gonna start making
some survival lists
what are the three things i have to do
right now i've got to get my income up
i've got to get a driver's license and
i've got to find a place to live
those are survival things that you need
to do right now this week
you need to go get your driver take your
driver's license test and get get past
and then you need to be working like a
maniac
anything you can do
70 80 hours a week for this month that
you've got with your grandmother go
crazy
and if you can get her to give you one
more month just to say i've gotta pile
up some cash so i can get out of here
grandmother i get it i know you want the
house i know you want me out of here i'm
out of here but if you'll give me one
more month i can save up the money to
get me a little car and i'm gonna load
it up and i'm gonna head east
out of california and go find a less
expensive place to live than san
francisco and start your life and start
a career and start some education and
get some counseling for all the things
that have happened to you
and start to start the healing process
plug into a good church along the way
but right now you need a driver's
license you need a car you need six jobs
right now so you can pile up as much
money to solve this as fast as possible
you need sustainability
that's what we're after
i'm so sorry kiddo you call back if we
can help you we'll try
this is the ramsey show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way at a financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you